Der FCM hat die rote Laterne zurück, Schalke thront wieder an der Spitze. Und sonst ist eigentlich pures Chaos angesagt. Wir wollen über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer nach dem 25. Spieltag sprechen. Und das machen wir mit Kevin Bublitz vom Baader Cast und Thomas Haufe vom Nur der FCM Podcast. Und jetzt geht's los.
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Lageralp fliegt vorbei, der Ball ist im Tor!
Und Augsburg ist oben!
Russis zu kurz Abwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Markner, Martin Markner.
Und das Anzündung. Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja, wir kommen zurück zur Ligatour, zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Mein Name ist Eva-Lotta Bohle. Und keine Angst, ich habe Marc nicht rausgeschmissen oder sonst irgendwas. Irgendwie. Aber der war leider krank und deshalb konnte die letzte Folge eben auch nicht regulär erscheinen. Wir mussten die komplett ausfallen lassen. Das hatte einfach ein bisschen was bei uns in der Organisation zu tun und mit Terminen, die man leider einfach mal nicht gerade so eben verschieben konnte. Deshalb sorry dafür, dass es dafür eben auch keinen Ersatz gab. Aber wir sind jetzt wieder da und ich darf an meiner Seite ein absolutes Traumduo begrüßen. Es ist das, man könnte sagen Traumduo des All-Star-Teams. Zum einen ist Thomas Haufe vom Nur der FCM Podcast mal wieder mit dabei. Hallo, Thomas. Du bist noch stumm.
Ja, die Frage ist halt auch für mich, auch nach dem Schalke-Spiel, welche Rolle spielt tatsächlich auch das Trainerteam dann? Ich hoffe, dass das natürlich nur öffentlich passiert und dass man da intern auch ganz anders spricht. Aber was mir hier aufgefallen ist, und das hat mich sehr gestört, dass man nach dem Schalke-Spiel auf der Pressekonferenz und auf Vorbereitung auf das nächste Spiel angesprochen wurde, auf diese 5 Gegentore, die man gegen Schalke bekommen hat. Und sich der Trainer dann hinstellt und sagt, naja, seht doch nicht alles so negativ, wir haben doch auf Schalke 3 Tore geschossen. Wo ich mir dachte, alter, was ist denn jetzt los? Wir können uns doch dafür nichts kaufen, dass du 3 Tore auf Schalke schießt, aber 5er halt bekommst. Das Gleiche jetzt nach dem Spiel gegen, nach dem 1-3 jetzt gegen Karlsruhe, wo er sich dann hinstellt und nach dem Spiel bei Sky sagt, auf die Frage, dann wieder 3 Gegentore, wie wollen sie denn jetzt zukünftig das Defensivverhalten verbessern? Das dritte Tor rechne ich da jetzt einfach mal raus, wo ich mir denke, hä, das war doch ein reguläres Tor während der Spielzeit und das steht doch auf der Anzeigetafel und ist doch auch in der Wertung drin. Also wieso rechne ich denn das denn in meiner Betrachtung dieses Spiels raus? Und da tue ich mich sehr, sehr schwer mit, mit solchen Äußerungen. Und ich hoffe, dass das wirklich nur nach außen getan wird, um da alles ein bisschen runterzuspielen, dass man das intern natürlich ganz, ganz anders anspricht. Und weil so mit der Defensive kann es nicht weitergehen. Du kannst nicht jedes Spiel drei oder vier Tore schießen, um wenigstens einen Punkt zu holen. Das funktioniert nicht. Und der Ansatz, den man jetzt gegen Elbersberg gewählt hat, mal so 10, 15 Meter tiefer zu stehen, Elbersberg, das eben nicht diese Räume zu gehen, dass sie mit Schnelligkeit dann oder mit Geschwindigkeit dann auf den 16er zugehen können, sondern zu sagen, okay, wir stehen tiefer, ihr müsst ein bisschen anders spielen. Das macht mir ein bisschen Hoffnung tatsächlich, dass man erkannt hat, dass es eben mit dieser brutal offensiven Spielweise, wo du den Gegnern 40 Meter vorm Tor richtig böse Räume gibst, wo sie dann reinlaufen können. Ich hoffe, dass das der Weg ist, den man jetzt weitergehen wird. Da muss man aber natürlich auch einen Ticken effizienter vorne werden, weil die Chancen wären natürlich weniger mit so einer Spielweise. Aber ich sage ganz ehrlich, nach den letzten Wochen, ich sehe lieber so ein Spiel wie gegen Elbersberg als noch mal so eine Kicke wie gegen Couto oder Schalke mir angucken zu müssen. Da sage ich ganz ehrlich.
Kevin, du wolltest, glaube ich, auch noch etwas sagen.
Warum hat man Patrick Sander verpflichtet? Ich habe dich das, glaube ich, beim letzten Mal, als wir zusammen waren, schon mal gefragt. Ich verstehe es bis heute nicht. Aber ich finde das total krass, das habe ich bis heute nicht verstanden. Verein mit dem Umfeld, mit der Vita und dem Aufschwung der letzten Jahre, dass die keinen anderen Staff oder Trainer finden, so wie du es gerade gesagt hast, die auch ganz anders auftreten nach außen und nicht so als dieses gebückte Ding, doch war so schlecht, war es ja gar nicht. Mein Gott, besser geht es halt nicht bei uns. Das finde ich total schwierig. Ich finde auch, es wird dem Verein nicht gerecht. Das finde ich für die Fans total schade. Ich bin da, weiß Gott, nicht so nah dran, aber ich weiß nicht, mir tut das auch ein bisschen weh, das zu sehen, wie die Entwicklung da ist. Vor allem, wenn man den Fußball der letzten Jahre sieht vom FCM. Es ist schon bitter. Und wenn man sieht, der letzte Heimsieg, 29. November, habe ich gerade noch mal geguckt. Ich habe echt lange scrollen müssen. Alter Schwede.
Die Mannschaft hat sich auf jeden Fall schon in die Geschichtsbücher des Vereins eingetragen. Neun Heimwiederlehrer hat man noch nie.
Das ist krass und das war eine Bastion mal. Ich weiß noch, als wir in der 3. Liga zu euch gefahren sind, hatten wir jedes Mal die Buchse voll. Da haben wir immer gedacht, boah, in Magdeburg willst du nicht spielen.
Aber das ist schon seit…
Ich weiß, das ist lange her.
Also, letzte Saison war zu Hause auch schon katastrophal. Wir waren, glaube ich, auch 18er an der Heimtabelle. Man muss sich mal vorstellen, 18er und dann trotzdem Fünfte gewonnen am Ende. Das sagt doch viel über die Liga letztes Jahr. Aber auch das Jahr davor. Also, das ist so, seit zwei, drei Jahren ist das zu Hause… Katastrophe, ja. Also, wie gesagt, diese Saison die Krönung. Also, so schlecht waren wir nicht mal in diesem rotten, schlechten Jahr, 10, 11, wo wir nur drin geblieben sind wegen der Regionalliga-Reform damals. Und seitdem, selbst diese Mannschaft, hat es geschafft, nur achtmal zu Hause zu verlieren. Die Gruppe hat es jetzt echt geschafft, wahrscheinlich eine Ewigkeit aufzustellen.
Also, bei euch bin ich wirklich gespannt auf das nächste Programm, so was zu kommen, weil ihr habt so Top-Mannschaft-Gegner, dann so Konkurrent, dann wieder Top-Mann, also so ein Wechsel. Ich glaube, es könnte euch sogar zu Gute kommen, weil auch die Mannschaften oben immer wieder mal straucheln. Aber ihr werdet auch so ein paar Teams haben, die vielleicht– Eva hat es vorhin schon woanders gesagt– die dann vielleicht schon durch sind. Man denkt immer so, das ist dann einfacher. Manchmal ist das ja auch weit gefehlt.
Klassische 6-6 oder so.
Also zum Beispiel so Heimspiel gegen Hertha. Schönen Grüß an Marc. Aber mal weghören, Marc. Aber das wäre doch prädestiniert zum Beispiel, um da schon mal drei Punkte einzupreisen.
Ja, das ist natürlich immer die Gefahr. Spiel in ein paar Lagerbunden geht bestimmt auch was. Wir haben an den letzten beiden Spielen Kaiserslautern und Hertha. Von daher bin ich die zwei Teams, die dann auf jeden Fall durch sind. Und das kann gut sein, das kann aber natürlich auch richtig schlecht sein. Weil dann eben für die geht es um nichts mehr. Und für die eine Mannschaft geht es um alles. Das ist immer so ein zweischneidiges Schwert. Kleine Info noch für die, die es vielleicht nicht auf dem Schirm haben. Es folgt jetzt das Heimspiel gegen Darmstadt. Das wird allerdings ohne einen Teil der Fans stattfinden. Da gab es einen Teilausschluss von der– Lass es mich gerade kon- Ja, schwierig. So, nochmal von vorne anfangen, den Satz. Lass es mich korrekt wiedergeben. Die Blöcke 3 bis 6 der Nordtribüne, die werden gesperrt werden. Das ist eben ein Ergebnis bzw. die Sanktion nach den gewaltsamen Ausschreitungen gegen Dynamo Dresden. Ich bin sicher, die Videos haben viele von euch gesehen. Ich glaube, da brauchen wir jetzt nicht so ins Detail geben. Insgesamt noch eine Geldstrafe von 186.600 Euro. Auch das, was den Verein wahrscheinlich nicht so richtig top treffen wird in der aktuellen Situation. Das ist eben das Spiel auf weitere Bewehrungen ausgesetzt. Falls es jetzt eben im Spiel darauf zur Ausschreitung kommen sollte, kann es eben auch sein, dass man im Endspurt weiterhin auf seine Fans verzichtet. Der FCM hat dem übrigens ohne Erwiderung zugestimmt. Auch das, wir haben es gerade darüber diskutiert, Heimstärke ist eh nicht. Haufe, jetzt mal vorsichtig formuliert.
Ja, Gott, jetzt kriege ich Schlag irgendwo im MWF.
Ja, ich meine, das ist dann natürlich auch immer ein bisschen Spekulation, aber ja, also ich kann nur sagen, Thomas, ich fühle da natürlich sehr mit dir mit im Abstiegskampf, aber ich habe auch einfach entschieden, ich mache gar keine Prognosen mehr. Also ich ärgere mich seit drei Wochen schwarz, hätten wir dieses Spiel gegen Fürth einfach gewonnen, dann wäre es glaube ich alles ein bisschen entspannter. Aber ich kenne das, hier spricht man auch seit, nach den knappen Niederlagen gegen Hannover und Schalke, ist es eben auch dieses so, naja, eigentlich haben wir ja gar nicht so schlecht gespielt. Und Schalke gewinnt nur, weil unser Torhüter da schlecht steht gegen Hannover, das ist ein Elfmeter, und eigentlich schießen wir da ja auch zwei Mal Tore, die werden aber auch beide Male aberkannt. Und ich merke das als Fan auch selber, dass du dich in so Szenarien verfängst und immer denkst, ah ja, da, und du fängst halt an zu rechnen, und das ist immer ganz schlecht. Den Tabellenrechner, den schmeiß ich gar nicht erst an, gerade nicht in dieser Liga, wo alles irgendwie noch drin ist. Aber du rechnest irgendwie alles durch und fängst an, wie wütend zu werden, weil gegnerische Vereine irgendwie nicht ihren Job machen. Und du denkst, ja, gegen uns hätten sie das ja auch mal machen können. Das ist einfach super nervig und ich weiß das noch von unserem Abstiegsjahr vor ein paar Jahren. Du hast immer kein Bock mehr und du wirst es sicherlich dann auch noch jede Woche drüber zu reden. Du denkst ja auch immer so, ja, selben Song nochmal.
Ihr kennt es ja auch aus der Hinrunde, also von daher.
Ja, es geht einfach immer weiter.
Aber wenn es dann wie eine Hinrunde gleichmäßig verläuft, dann reicht es ja am Ende.
Hm, glaube ich nicht. Also ich denke schon, wir haben ja in den letzten vier Spielen zehn Punkte gewonnen. Ich glaube, das wird diesmal nicht reichen, weil die da unten einfach auch inzwischen konstanter Punkte. Guckt ihr die Resten an, die spielen eine überragende Rückrunde für ihre Verhältnisse. Und das führt jetzt erkannt, Mensch, wenn wir nur zwei, drei Spiele gewinnen, haben wir auch eine Chance, da unten rauszukommen. Also diese zehn Punkte, die werden nicht reichen. Also ich denke schon, dass du am Ende fünf, sechsunddreißig, siebenunddreißig, vielleicht sogar achtunddreißig Punkte brauchst, um sicher drin zu bleiben. Und also mal gucken.
Ja, das Problem ist einfach…
Ich habe die Rechnung aufgemacht für uns, du brauchst minimum noch vier Siege. Mir fehlt gerade tatsächlich so ein bisschen der Glaube gegen, wen wir die holen sollen.
Ich kann dir die nennen, aber das springt die Sendung.
Ja, ich glaube, das ganz große Problem, was wir da haben…
Wie Franko Münzt immer an.
Das finde ich einen super Plan. Aus ganz uneigenden Zingründen. Nee, was natürlich ein wirklich spannendes Thema unironisch noch sein wird, ist das Torverhältnis. Also wir haben Magdeburg mit minus 13, Braunschalke mit minus 15, Führer mit minus 19. So, führt weiterhin schlechteste Defensive der Liga. Brauchen wir nicht lange darüber reden. Aber Magdeburg folgt dann eben darauf. Also das ist eben das Ding. Und das wird, glaube ich… Also, ich sage auch mal so, dir werden die Punkte nicht nur reichen. Es wird wirklich zum Ende hin ganz, ganz viel darauf ankommen, wie du gewinnst oder verlierst du die Spiele eben. Weil dafür ist das unten alles viel zu nah beieinander. Und du willst nicht am letzten Spieltag so einen… Einfach nur darauf gucken, ah, okay, gewinnt die Mannschaft jetzt 3-1 oder 4-1? So, ne? Was brauchen wir? Wie viele Tore brauchen wir? Wie viele Tore müssen die anderen kassieren? Das willst du ja am letzten Spieltag auf jeden Fall vermeiden. Weil dann ist dann… Also, ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendein Spieler ablegen kann. Also dann rechnest du ja nur noch. Also dann… Fans rechnen nur, verantwortlich rechnen nur. Das ist das Schlechteste, was dir hinten raus, ehrlich gesagt, passieren kann. Ähm, von daher… Ja, bin ich mal gespannt. Ich meine, du siehst jetzt bei Bielefeld, die stehen eigentlich nur so gut da, weil sie noch ein positives Torverhältnis haben, ne? Also, da wäre es schon ein paar Mal weiter unten in der Tabelle gewesen, dann hätte man eben nicht zu Anfang der Saison und zum Teil da hohe Siege eingefahren. Und das ist eben das Problem, Thomas, was du eben auch schon mal so ein bisschen angesprochen hast, ist ja schön und gut, dass man da drei Tore schießt und da fünf Tore schießt. Aber wenn du gleichzeitig halt auch immer vier oder fünf kassierst, ist die Rechnung halt ganz, ganz schnell weg. Und dann ist auch vollkommen egal, wie das eine Tor gefallen ist und bla. Das ist dann egal. Und wenn du das ist, ich mache auch einen Phrasenschwein auf, du musst die Tore vorne machen. Und das Ding ist ja wirklich, die Torschüsse hast du ja. Also du kommst ja in die Position, auch Torschüsse zu machen. Aber alleine davon, ich glaube, irgendwie hat irgendwie seine 45 XG oder so, also zehn Tore mehr hätte man schon mal schießen sollen, was trotzdem gemessen an der Menge der Torschüsse, die du abgibst, ja auch irgendwie nicht so ganz aufgeht. Also das ist eben das große Problem, was sich eben durchzieht, die defensivste Stabilität, die fehlt und gleichzeitig eben offensiv. Wir sind gespannt. Wie gesagt, zu Hause gegen Darmstadt, auswärts in Münster sind die nächsten Partien. Bevor wir auf unser letztes Spiel kommen, habe ich noch Ankündigungen mitgebracht, beziehungsweise erstmal so eine kleine Feedback-Schleife, das hatten wir hier noch nicht so richtig, aber ich wollte einmal Danke sagen, auch wenn es vier Wochen näher ist, für das Feedback zur letzten Folge, natürlich im Forum, unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de, aber eben auch bei YouTube. Und da ganz besonders eben auch Danke an die Schalke-Fans. Ich weiß, manchen von euch hat das vielleicht nicht so gut gefallen. Ich glaube, wir hatten im Kern trotzdem richtige Punkte, aber ihr habt oder ein paar User haben auf jeden Fall auch richtige Punkte gemacht, die wir so eben nicht erwähnt haben und nicht auf dem Schirm hatten. Und Kritik ist eigentlich immer gerne willkommen, vor allem, wenn es konstruktive Kritik ist, weil damit kann ich oder können wir als All-Star-Team tatsächlich am besten was mit anfangen, als wenn ihr einfach nur drunter schreibt, ja, fand ich scheiße. Also, dann ist okay, könnt ihr machen, aber damit kann ich tatsächlich sehr wenig mit anfangen. Und tatsächlich auch nochmal der Hinweis, wenn es euch so sehr triggert, dass ich gendersensible Sprache benutze, tut es mir leid, aber ich werde deshalb damit nicht aufhören. Da müsst ihr dann entweder mit klarkommen oder euch tatsächlich einfach dann einen anderen Podcast suchen, so leid es mir tut. Aber viele von euch, die sind weiterhin dabei und sind auch Unterstützerinnen, Supporterinnen und Supporterinnen, denn ihr wisst es, der Werbe, der Rasenfunk ist werbepaywall und sponsor- und frei, nicht der Werbefunk. Das wäre was anderes. Vielen Dank, dass ihr viele von euch eben schon bereits Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter seid. Wenn ihr das werden wollt, guckt gerne mal in den Shownotes. Wenn es ein Euro im Monat ist, freuen wir uns darüber. Weil ihr finanziert damit eben nicht nur Max, sondern eben auch unsere Gastinnen und eben Marc und mich als Moderatorin. Und ihr finanziert die Menge an Sendungen, die eben rauskommt. Gestern, also am Sonntag, ist die Folge zu den Qualispielen der Frauen erschienen. Die haben ja insgesamt neun Tore geschossen. Heute ist zur Bundesliga-Sendung der Männer eine Folge entschieden. Da habe ich mich erfolgreich von Martin Raffelt geratespaitet. Ich sehe Bielefeld in der Folgenbeschreibung. Ich denke mir so, was hat Dortmund jetzt gerade mit Bielefeld zu tun und warum mussten sie auf einem Acker spielen? Letzte Woche ist die Ligatour Europa erschienen. Eventuell erscheint diese Woche noch ein Schwerpunkt. Das ist aber noch nicht so ganz klar, da einfach die Augen und Ohren offen halten. Und sonst kann ich schon mal sagen, nächste Folge erscheint in zwei Wochen. Dann werden wir wahrscheinlich wieder die Länderspielpause für drei Wochen nutzen, weil es einfach mehr Sinn ergibt, dann doch eigentlich immer zwei Spieltage abzuwarten. Gerade jetzt zum Saison-Endspurt hin, weil sonst hört die hier tatsächlich, glaube ich, auch zum Ende hin immer die gleiche Leier. Und das möchte wirklich niemand. So, wir kommen auf unser letztes Spiel. Und das war zwischen Münster und Hertha BSC. Und ich sage schon mal, die Vereine oder die Tore, die da gefallen sind, die waren gar nicht mal der größte Star dieses Spiels, sondern ein Kabel. Dazu gleich mehr. Das zweite Spiel in Folge. Auch das nach den geplatzten Ausstiegsträumen gewinnt Hertha BSC knapp mit 2 zu 1. Dabei sorgt eben vor allem ein Stromkabel für viel Aufmerksamkeit. Kurz vor der Pause vor Cooles Cuisance. Nach VR-Prüfung gibt es Elfmeter. Den verwandelt Reese auch. Allerdings wird diese Entscheidung von Videoschiedsrichterin Katrin Rafalski getroffen, denn der Bildschirm in Münster bleibt schwarz. Schiedsrichter Bickel sieht nichts und sagt dann eben auch durch meine Kollegin Katrin Rafalski, hat eben diesen Kontakt gesehen. Grund dafür ist, dass Mitglieder der Fans in Münster sich Zutritt zum Innenraum verschafft haben und den Stecker gezogen haben, das mit dem Spruchband, dem VR, den Stecker ziehen, direkt bestätigt haben. Es ist ein super Bild, wenn da oben noch drüber steht auf der Tribüne. Ich glaube, gemeinsam digitale Lösungen verwicklichen. Das waren 10 von 10 Text-Wildschirre. Das ist tatsächlich ein Bild der Saison, könnte man tatsächlich sagen. Münster und der DFB ermitteln. Man muss dazu sagen, im Münster-Stadion wird umgebaut. Ihr werdet das alle mitbekommen haben. Daher befindet sich die Fanszene von Preuß Münster gerade im ehemaligen Gäste-Blog und so eben auch näher dran an diesem TV-Bildschirm. Und ja, trotzdem muss ich auch sagen, sah tatsächlich sehr witzig aus. Und ich war tatsächlich sehr verwirrt, dass man so einfach wirklich dieses komplette Konstrukt einmal ausschalten kann, indem man einfach einen Stecker zieht und man ihn tatsächlich einfach nicht wieder reinstecken kann. Und dann funktioniert es wieder. Also es war nicht, ja, doch, durch, ich glaube, jeder ITler dachte da auch nur so, naja, wir können noch nicht mal sagen, have you tried turning the gate off? Notfallmanagement.
Notfallmanagement, so wichtig.
Das hat mich auf jeden Fall abgeholt. Aber zurück zum Spiel. Münster kann durch Heuer kurz noch wieder ein Fünf ausgleichen. Die Comeback-Münsterranne schlagen da nochmal kurz zu. Das letzte Wort, das hat dann allerdings Martin Winkler, der nach einem Konter in der dritten Minute der Nachspielzeit zum 2-1 vollendet. Wir schauen zuerst auf Preußen Münster. Die stehen momentan auf Platz 14, 26 Punkte, 30 zu 38 Tore, 6 Siege, 8 Unentschieden, 11 Niederlagen. In der Formtabelle, da ist man im Gegensatz zur letzten Sendung ein bisschen nach oben geklettert. Platz 14 ist es, ein Sieg, ein Unentschieden, zwei Niederlagen. Es gab einen wichtigen Sieg gegen Braunschweig letzte Woche. Davor eine knappe Niederlage gegen Kaiserslautern und ein Unentschieden gegen Bochum. Es ist Thomas die Mannschaft, die die zweitmeisten Punkte nach Rückstand holt. 14 sind es bisher, 19 Mal musste man bisher einen Rückstand hinnehmen. Drei Siege, fünf Unentschieden und elf Niederlagen. Das ist ja eigentlich schon mal eine ganz gute Quote. Allerdings muss man ehrlich gesagt sagen, dafür gerät man wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu oft in Rückstand. Was glaubst du denn? Also man hat ja zwischendurch eigentlich das Gefühl, Preußen ist eigentlich ganz gut dabei. Die werden mit dem Abstieg vielleicht eher nichts zu tun haben. Wir wissen alle, unter Ende hat man gut in Fußball gespielt. Aber jetzt so zuletzt, es sah schon noch mal schlechter aus, aber man hat so ein bisschen das Gefühl, man schlägt sich häufig einfach mit eigenen Waffen und mit Unaufmerksamkeiten. Siehst du das auch so?
Ja, ein schönes Beispiel ist der Strafstoß zum 0 zu 1. Das zieht sich ja dann auch. Die Frage ist immer, ist es dann nur Pech, wie man ja gerne mal sagt, dass die unten stehenden Mannschaften Pech haben, oder ist es dann eben doch in dem Fall dann einfach fehlende Qualität, die dann eben dafür sorgt, dass man in solchen Zweikämpfen zu spät da ist oder sich halt einfach auch ein bisschen dämlich anstellt in solchen Situationen. Von daher schwierig, aber ich glaube Münster ist das, also da wird jetzt keiner unruhig, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Denen war von Anfang an klar, es geht nur gegen den Abstieg. Die sind in der Rolle, in der sie in meinen Augen von Saisonbeginn auch sich gesehen haben, denke ich mal. Ich glaube nicht, da hatte keiner Höhenflüge und hat gesagt, wir werden die Tabelle 8er oder so. Ich glaube, die Träume hatte man in Münster nicht. Von daher denke ich schon, die sind im Soll. Die sind da, wo sie stehen sollen, stehen immer noch über dem Strich. Ich habe schon gesagt, dass die Formtabelle ist okay für eine Mannschaft von da unten. Die haben das wichtige Spiel gegen Braunschweig gewonnen. Also diese direkten Duellen, die holen sie. Hertha ist ja nun, auch wenn die jetzt so diesen Aufstiegskampf für sich beendet haben, aber Hertha ist ja nun auch trotzdem keine Laufkundschaft. Ist ja trotzdem eine starke Mannschaft. Und die haben sie so lange, die haben sie wirklich gut bespielt. Am Ende dann in der Nachspielzeit das 1 zu 2 kassiert. Also ich glaube, Münster muss sich weniger Sorgen machen als der eine oder andere Verein unten.
Kevin, wie schaust du auf die Münsteraner?
Erst einen Sieg in der Rückrunde und dann auch mal in Braunschweig. Das ist jetzt auch nicht so, das ist dann ein Achtungserfolg. Ich weiß, das ist jetzt gerade schwierig für mich, das Argument rauszuholen, aber es ist halt auch in Braunschweig. Ja, das war jetzt irgendwie nicht so klug, aber gut.
Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel, was?
Ja, du hast vorhin gesagt, wir bauen immer solche Mannschaften auf. Wir machen das in Badawan auch gern. Ja, weiß ich nicht, also das ist mir zu wenig. Ein paar Unentschieden, 1-1 dabei. Jetzt verlierst du gegen die Hertha zu Hause, für die angeblich alles schon gelaufen war. Da können wir gleich noch drüber sprechen, ob die jetzt ins Geheimtuch wieder hoffen. Ich bin da nicht so sicher. Die müssen jetzt nach Dresden, dann gegen Magdeburg. Das sind zwei Spiele. Dann nach Kiel, Altersschede.
Guck mal weiter.
Und dann nach Fürth, ach du liebe Güte. Also eigentlich hat Münster jetzt ein Endprogramm. Also die müssen jetzt vorlegen. Ich glaube, die sind nicht so entspannt. Letzte Saison haben die auch eine ziemliche Kurzschlussreaktion auf dem Trainerposten irgendwann mal getätigt.
Aber alles richtig gemacht.
Ja gut, das sehe ich tatsächlich, glaube ich nicht. Weil damit musst du vor der Saison gerechnet haben. Dafür war Alex Ende von Anfang an natürlich ein gewisses Risiko als Trainer eben auch. Aber jetzt nochmal, sie spielen entweder gegen direkte Abstiegskonkurrenten oder nur noch gegen Mannschaften von oben. Also Dresden, Magdeburg, Kiel führt, Schalke, Bielefeld, Hannover, Darmstadt, Helversberg.
Ich weiß nicht warum. Ich versuche mal, meine persönlichen Strömungen auszublenden. Und da fehlt mir dann trotzdem die Fantasie, wie Münster, also wie Münster, also Münster ist für mich eine der Kandidaten noch und auf die letzten drei Plätze rutschen wird. Weil Thomas, so was gesagt, Dresden glaube ich nicht, dass sie da was holen. Ich würde, sie sind sehr stark unterwegs in dieser Rekunde.
Sehr stabil, ja.
So jetzt zu Hause gegen euch, okay. Aber da habe ich eher gedacht, da könntet ihr vielleicht was landen und dann weiß ich nicht. Also ich sehe gerade nicht diesen Push, den Münster irgendwo herholt. Ich weiß nicht. Also klar kann man jetzt sagen, den hat natürlich Magdeburg auch nicht. So, aber ich habe bei Münster gerade kein Gefühl und das ist immer so schlechter als ein Gefühl zu haben, finde ich. Ich kann das nicht ganz begründen. Ich finde die Spiele zu ineffektiv, zu viel Graue.
Ja, ich glaube einfach so ein bisschen das, was…
Sorry, da fehlen die Adjektive.
Ne, alles gut. Das, was zu Beginn der Saison eben zum Teil sehr, sehr gut funktioniert hat, das geht halt jetzt zum Teil nicht mehr auf. Gleichzeitig bist du super abhängig von jemandem, wie meiner Meinung nach Battista Meyer. Also, der bringt seine Qualität mit, aber ich habe schon so das Gefühl, dass also, ob er trifft, ob er nicht trifft, das kann schon mal so ein Spiel entscheiden. Für super torell entscheidende Spiele, ich weiß, das ist der Hot Take des Tages.
Wir überschlagen uns heute hier.
Aber ihr wisst, was ich damit meine, das ist schon jemand, der kann eben mit seiner individuellen Qualität viel machen. Ich bin auch weiterhin der Meinung, er macht natürlich auch viel. Aber klar ist es ein gutes Zeichen, dass du als Mannschaft nie aufgibst und eben noch 14 Punkte nach Rückstand geholt hast. Aber gleichzeitig, ich sag's gerne nochmal, 19 Rückstände. Das heißt nicht, dass das nicht nach Spielen geht, sondern wirklich, wie oft du in einem Spiel in Rückstand geraten bist. Dann sind 11 Niederlagen halt auch immer noch relativ viel. Im Vergleich dazu hat Darmstadt 15 Punkte aus 10 Rückständen geholt. Du siehst dann natürlich auch, ist natürlich fies der Vergleich. Aber ich sehe es immer wieder bei Münster-Fans in meiner Timeline, die einfach sagen, es ist eigentlich jede Woche das Gleiche. Du denkst eben, es ist jetzt gar nicht, dass wir klar unterlegen sind in irgendeiner Art und Weise. Du siehst jetzt irgendwie nicht, das und das ist nicht Zweitligatauglich, aber wie bei so vielen Mannschaften gerade da unten drin, dir fehlt eben die Durchschlagskraft. Und das ist einfach, also ich glaube tatsächlich aus mehreren Gründen einfach auch, wann dieses Spiel stattfindet, ist das Derby gegen Bielefeld für beide Mannschaften, ist da richtig, richtig viel drin. Weil das kann, alleine in der Position, in der Tabelle, kann das richtig viel, also kann das vielleicht sogar entscheidende drei Punkte sein hinten raus. Natürlich dann total entspannt, dass es so stattfindet. Aber ja, also man muss halt sagen, Hertha war ja durchaus auch schlagbar in diesem Spiel. Also Hertha hatte ein typisches Hertha-Spiel zuletzt. Ich meine, die haben jetzt ein Spiel zuvor gewonnen, ja in Nürnberg, wenn ich mich an sich alles täusche, ja. Und jetzt eben das Spiel, es ist, ja, du merkst bei denen, wir reden gleich noch über den, da sind irgendwie 80 andere Probleme auch immer noch am Start. Und du weißt, da scheint auch einfach trotzdem auf dem Feld so ein bisschen die Luft raus. Ja, aber Münster, also ich glaube weiterhin für viele Vereine da unten drin sind Braunschweig und Kiel zwei Punkte. Einfach weil Braunschweig, ja, die sind erprobt im Abstiegskampf. Aber jedes Jahr da wieder drin zu stecken, das muss irgendwann, also ich habe das Gefühl, da kann es halt auch jetzt irgendwann mal knallen. So richtig nochmal, gerade auch da, weil das Derby ansteht. Und Kiel haben wir eben auch in Lengen drüber gesprochen. Also das kann für Vereine wie Münster, weil es können eben nicht fünf Vereine absteigen. Das ist einfach so zwei Steine. Auch nochmal Hot Take, aber zwei Vereine steigen ab, eine geht in die Relegation. Wenn man gerade in die 3. Liga guckt, weiß man da auch nicht, wie man da am wenigsten haben will, ehrlich gesagt. So geht es mir auf jeden Fall. Ich wollte eigentlich nicht nach Ferl, um da Relegation zu spielen. Ja, also weiß ich nicht. Es ist, ich würde sie noch nicht komplett abschreiben, sowieso nicht von der Tabellensituation, aber ich sehe auf jeden Fall deine Punkte, Kevin. Aber ich kann halt auch nicht so, ich sehe halt nicht, wie wir haben über Magdeburg über defensive Instabilität gesprochen. Wir haben bei Führer darüber gesprochen, dass sie das wieder geschafft haben. Bei Münster sehe ich halt nicht so das eine ganz große Problem, wo man wirklich direkt sagen kann, okay, das gehen wir jetzt einfach mal an. Und das ist, glaube ich, die Schwierigkeit, weil sie machen ja immer noch viel richtig.
Ich kann die total schwer greifen, ich weiß auch nicht. Also sie stehen ja eigentlich sogar auf Platz 14 richtig, weil Heim- und Auswärtstabelle sind sie 14. Insofern wird da ein Argument, dass sie da vielleicht bleiben. Übrigens krass, was Nürnberg nur acht Auswärtspunkte wollte. Egal, anderes Thema. Aber ich kann Münster einfach nicht fassen. Vielleicht bin ich da auch einfach so nicht bewandert genug bei dem Club. Ich habe bei denen irgendwie keine so richtige Meinung. Mir fehlte gerade so die springende Fantasie, dass sie jetzt die nächsten vier Spiele gewinnen könnten. Definitiv vom Potenzial her. Und dann durchwehren, dass sie die auch wirklich gewinnen. Die Historie dieser 2. Liga lässt mich daran zweifeln, dass eine Mannschaft vier Spiele in Folge unten im Tabellenkeller gewinnen wird gegen direkte Konkurrenten. Und dann kommen ja noch die Mannschaften oben. Also das spricht für mich. Ich weiß nicht warum. Klar, man könnte jetzt sagen, Kevin ist ja Quatsch, weil die können ja jetzt mit den nächsten vier Spielen alles klar machen. Dann können sie auch gegen die oben verlieren. Ich sage, sie gewinnen aber nicht alle vier gegen diese Mannschaften unten und kriegen dann noch auf den Deckel von denen, die oben stehen. Und dann haben sie das schlechteste Momentum hinten raus. Ach, egal.
Ich rede mir um Kopf und Kran. Ich sage gerne nochmal, ich prognose, ich lasse es einfach. Ich lasse es einfach bleiben. Es ist für mich, wenn ich so ein bisschen meine Kontonance behalten will, dann reg ich mich auch weniger auf, wenn es hinterher geht. Ich glaube, ich bin das Quatsch.
Ich sage mal, so viert wurde ich ja auch schon tot geredet.
Wie gesagt, bei Dresden habe ich auch schon dreimal gesagt, also die haben sich ja verbessert, aber ich sehe es nicht langfristig. Ja, schauen wir mal.
Das muss jetzt aber auch erstmal weiter punkten. Das kann ja jetzt auch so ein schöner März gewesen sein. Und dann ist es jetzt wieder...
Ich habe ja per se weniger, aber gut.
Aber Münster hat es eben jetzt die nächsten vier Wochen in der Hand. Also das ist eben...
Danke.
Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Entschuldigung, Thomas.
Alles gut. Aber Münster hat es jetzt gegen direkte Konkurrenz in der Hand.
Die müssen jetzt direkt zünden, ja.
Und ich glaube, das ist jetzt auch einfacher, als diese Spiele hinten rauszuhaben. Ich glaube schon, dass bei den vermeintlichen Aufstiegskandidaten, die da am Ende kommen, geht ja dann auch das Denken los. Ich kann mich erinnern, Darmstadt damals, als sie vor drei Jahren aufgestiegen sind. Die haben auch drei Spiele gebraucht, um den Aufstieg dann fix zu machen. Da haben sich auch Schüler gefragt, wird das noch was? Und dann haben sie am vorletzten Spiel nach gegen uns dann den Aufstieg klargemacht. Aber die hatten dann auch drei Spiele davor, wo sie es hätten klar machen können und es einfach nicht geschafft haben. Ich glaube, ich werde vorsichtig zu sagen, wenn dann hinten raus die Schwerenbrunnen kommen, auch die müssen dann erst mal noch über diese Ziellinie gehen.
Das Münster-Letzte-Sorte.
Schauen wir mal. Okay.
Letzte-Sorte Münster am Ende, das ist vermutlich leichtere Programm.
Also ich glaube, wie gesagt, ich würde das Wort leicht einfach in dieser Liga nicht mehr in den Mund nehmen. Das ist wirklich… Das ist einfach… also ich glaube, wie gesagt, bis auf gefühlt vier Vereine wird da am Ende, das wird, weiß ich nicht, Mord und Totschlag ebenso ungefähr. Ja, das ist schon eine große Serie.
Jens hat als Tabellen-17. der letzte Saison am 32. Spieltag beim Tabellen-4. übrigens 5 zu 0 gewonnen. Das wollte ich nur mal erwähnen.
Ich erinnere mich.
Ja, und also das ist halt nicht unmöglich.
Ja, echt. Ja, und am letzten Spieltag ging Ulm, ne? 2-2.
Ja, es ist, es bleibt ein großes Fragezeichen. Aber ja, wo man sagen könnte, das Fragezeichen da ist eigentlich weg, ist bei Hertha BSC. Platz 6 ist es gerade, 40 Punkte. 36 zu 30 Tore, 11 Siege, 7 Unentschieden und 7 Niederlagen. Vorm Tabelle ist man Platz 10, 2 Siege, 2 Niederlagen. Ja, nach der 5 zu 2 Niederlage ging Paderborn und Stefan Leitel die Aufstiegspläne ad acta gelegt. Gleichzeitig weiß ich nicht, ob das jetzt für euch alle da draußen gut oder schlecht war, dass Marc direkt nach diesem Spiel hätte aufnehmen müssen. Ich glaube sogar mit dir, Kevin, vielleicht gut, dass es nicht der Welt entblickt habe. Ich glaube für die allgemeine gute Stimmung in dieser Gruppe war es besser, dass es diese Folge nicht gab. Heute hat der Körper von Marc da vorher einmal gesagt, wir lassen das lieber. Der hat doch schon was geahnt, was der Rest noch nicht so wusste. Aber Stefan Leithl hat eben selber gesagt, das ist jetzt nicht einfach etwas fürs Vierenraum geworfen hat, sondern Stefan Leithl hat sich hingestellt und hat gesagt, der Ausstieg ist bei uns nicht mehr drin. Es wurden, ich glaube, 1800 Abgesänger auf die alte Dame geschrieben. Weil man eben auch gesagt hat, du kannst sicherlich gegen Paderborn verlieren, aber die Art und Weise, wie man eben verloren hat, die waren ein bisschen zu viel. Davor hatte man eben auch eine Niederlage einstecken müssen. Man hat jetzt zwei Siege geholt per se, wenn man auf die Tabelle guckt. Klar sind es nur acht Punkte, aber ich glaube, man muss gleichzeitig sagen, dafür ist es da oben zu eng. Und da muss ja mindestens drei Teams hinter dich lassen. Das wird schon ehrlich gesagt eine Nummer. Jetzt hat man eben unter anderem in Münster gewonnen. Ich habe eben schon mal gesagt, ich hatte trotzdem ein bisschen das Gefühl, die Luft ist so ein bisschen raus. Also du merkst auch bei Lytle, der hat einiges Systemumstände, bzw. keine Systemumstellung gemacht, sondern du siehst so ein bisschen, da werden einigen Spieler schon deutliche Messages geschickt, sage ich mal vorsichtig. So nach dem Motto, okay, jetzt ist sowieso egal, dann können wir dich da auch wieder hinpacken und du kommst da raus. Das siehst du, glaube ich, schon. Also vorsichtig ausgedrückt. Also auch das zeigt eben überhaupt, dann ist es jetzt halt so. Kevin, vielleicht erst einmal kurz allgemein. Wir haben, ich glaube, in der Gruppe, generell auch vor der Saison, wir haben sehr kontrovers immer darüber diskutiert, was machen wir denn mit Hertha BSC? Weil der Verein ja selber sehr konfrontativ eben in diese Saison gegangen ist und offensiv gesagt hat, wir wollen aufsteigen. So, wir wissen alle, was finanziell bei der Hertha hintersteht, etc. Woran liegt es denn deiner Meinung nach jetzt, dass man eben schon einige, insgesamt glaube ich 11 Spieltage vor Schluss gesagt hat? Ja, also Aufstieg, 1. Liga ohne uns nächste Saison.
Also erstmal ist das ein richtiges Armutszeugnis für so ein Verein. Das hätte ich gerne auch mag, so gesagt, ohne jetzt gehässig sein zu wollen, aber das ist wirklich ein Armutszeugnis diese Saison, was die abgeliefert haben. Für das, was die sich vorgenommen haben, dass sie angeblich den idealen Trainer gefunden haben, der den Kader ja irgendwie auch mit zusammengestellt hat. Jetzt kann man immer draufhören und sagen, ja, das ist schlecht, wenn man so einen Star in der Mannschaft hat, der eigentlich schon längst woanders hätte spielen müssen. Rese meine ich natürlich zum Beispiel. Wäre es vielleicht doch besser gewesen, wenn man viele Spieler hat, die auf Augenhöhe agieren. Vielleicht. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Dazu bin ich nicht nahe genug an diesem Verein dran. Du hast zum Glück die Tipps nicht rausgeholt vor der Saison. Ich glaube, ich habe Hertha auf eins getippt, kann das sein. Aber auch nur zum ersten Mal seit langer Zeit, dass ich mal Experten-Tipps gemacht habe. Also mitgegangen bin. Ich glaube, ich habe Hertha, Schalke und Haufe auf die ersten drei Plätze getippt.
Einer von drei bist du schon mal gut.
Siehst du? Mit dem SCP habe ich auf Platz 7 getippt. Nachdem ich den jahrelang immer auf die ersten drei getippt habe, dachte ich mir, egal, woran liegt es bei der Hertha? Ich finde, das, was die gerade spielen, was du so beschrieben hast, die Luft ist raus, habe ich schon immer wieder in dieser Sorge gehabt, wo ich mir dachte, jetzt haben die gerade ein Spiel gewonnen oder zwei Spiele auch mal. Du hast das Gefühl, jetzt könnte ja diese berühmte Serie starten und dann hast du so wieder ein, zwei Spiele danach gehabt, wo auch Marc dann ja gesagt hat oder auch geschrieben hat bei uns in der WhatsApp-Gruppe. Krass eklatant, gar keine Ambition offenbar, dieses Spiel. Mal so diese berühmten Prozent auf die 100 draufzulegen und so eine Mannschaft niederzuspielen, auch einfach gegen die man da geht. Also auch das, Thomas, du hast vorhin gesagt, 2. Liga anzunehmen einfach. Das ist halt nicht einfach nur, wir sind die coolen Kicker aus Berlin, wir können richtig gut Fußball spielen. Eigentlich könnte ich auch zum BVB oder sowas wechseln. Sondern mir fehlt da so ein bisschen die Ernsthaftigkeit. Also dieses, was ich dem Trainer zum Beispiel nicht absprechen kann, der immer sehr verbissen wirkt und vielleicht auch da ein bisschen zu verbissen teilweise ist. Und das war eine absolute Trotzreaktion von ihm nach dem Spiel in Pärdervorne. Also es war wirklich wie so eine beleidigte Leberwurst, aber gleichzeitig auch sehr klar und eine realistische Einschätzung der Situation gegeben. Maßlos enttäuschter Trainer. Hab mich auch gewundert, dass er noch da ist. Aber wahrscheinlich auch, weil sie im Verein gesagt haben, okay, jetzt klappt es eh nicht mehr, dann machen wir das mit ihm noch diese Saison zu Ende oder so. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass der darüber hinaus bleiben wird. Boah, das ist eine ganz komische Situation in Berlin. Das ist die ganzen letzten Jahre mit Pall Dada und diese ganzen, also die Entwicklung ist nicht positiv. Du hast nicht so dieses, was du auch in Gelsenkirchen hattest, so dieses, boah, sie lernen nicht aus den Fehlern, was du in Hamburg lange Zeit hattest. Sie lernen nicht aus den Fehlern. Sie machen immer wieder den gleichen Quatsch und landen immer wieder auf der Nase. Und das hast du in Berlin auch. Das ist einfach der Punkt, offenbar noch nicht erreicht, wo sie sich sagen, so, und jetzt machen wir mal was ganz anders. Wir versuchen jetzt mal wirklich was Neues. Marc hatte ja diesen Berliner Weg auch hier in einer Sendung mal ganz nett skizziert. Man hatte ja vor, auch mit jungen Spielern zu arbeiten, und so weiter, Berliner Talente zu fördern. Ja, was bleibt aber nachher übrig? Ich bin halt einfach in der 2. Liga kein Freund, auch wenn er den Geko grad netzt wie sonst was davon, dass man halt ein, zwei Stars im Team hat. Das geht oft in die Hose, meiner Ansicht nach. Sowas, was wir die letzten Jahre gezeigt haben, auch welche Mannschaften letztendlich dann aufgestiegen sind. Weiß ich nicht.
Ja, also ich glaube, es kann natürlich schon funktionieren, aber es ist natürlich immer eine Frage. Natürlich. Ich habe bei JK auch die Frage gestellt, Zerstören, die Wintertransfer, so ein bisschen diese Geschlossenheit aus der Schalke agiert hat, sah kurz so aus. Sie haben sich wieder gefangen. Ich hatte, also das eben, was ich beispielsweise von Fabian Reese eben gestern gesehen hatte, ich finde, dem hast du bei jeder Aktion Frust angemerkt. Und der Mann ist halt Kapitän dieser Mannschaft. Also der, wo ich immer wieder auch zwischendurch gesagt habe, in seiner Best-Form ist Fabian Reese das Beste, was Hertha passieren kann. Wenn aber etwas, wo ich glaube nicht läuft, wie er sich das vorgestellt hat, und das wird dieser nicht gelungene Aufstieg gewesen sein, glaube ich schon, dass der auch gut zu kämpfen hat. Und das ist auch komplett menschlich, das will ich ihm überhaupt nicht absprechen. Aber dass du es so offensiv auf dem Platz siehst, sollte dir halt nicht passieren. Und ich habe da auch kurz mit Marc darüber gesprochen, der hat mir das auch bestätigt. Also das ist jetzt keine Außenwahl. Ich meine, ich habe immer auch wieder meine Kritik an Fabi Reese geäußert. Und ja, das kann halt in zwei Richtungen funktionieren. Aber wenn du halt siehst, dass das anstatt dass jemand wie Reese als Kapitän dann auch vorweggeht, aber du hast gerade bei ihm das Gefühl, das geht jetzt auch auf so ein Ego-Ding hinten raus. So, aber Hauptsache ich mache irgendwie noch mein Ding. Das ist ein Angriff, das ist mir bewusst, den ich jetzt auch an ihn äußere. Und man muss ja auch sagen, es hätte ja auch alles funktionieren können.
Hat ja die Sorge davor auch schon nicht funktioniert.
Naja, klar. Also, wie gesagt, Stefan Leitel… Den Padawan hast du ihn auch nicht gesehen. Bleibt da für mich auch weiterhin… Du hast eben seine Kommunikation ein bisschen angesprochen. Ich habe zwischendurch immer schon mal wieder gesagt, dass ich… Mir ist es vollkommen egal, wie der sich seinen… Mir ist es nicht vollkommen egal, wenn er schlimme Sachen macht. Es ist mir nicht egal. Aber im Sinne von, was er intern an sein Team weitergibt nach Punktverlusten etc. ist mir relativ egal. Persi erstmal. Aber du musst dich halt nach außen hin schon irgendwie präsentieren und eben dann nicht direkt wirken, wie halt so ein angefressenes Kind, was du dem das Eis gerade weggenommen hast. Und das war mir dann manchmal, es ist vollkommen okay, dass du enttäuscht bist. Aber als Trainer solltest du in dieser Situation da vielleicht nicht irgendwie direkt so eine Trotzreaktion. Und das hatte, glaube ich, auch rund um dieses Nürnbergs Spieler, der auch nochmal gesagt hat, ja, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, warum wir immer nicht direkt sein sollen. Ja, also ich meine, es ist ja auch vollkommen okay, dass man es klar benennt, dass der Ausstieg weg, also rein rechnerisch noch möglich ist. Rein fußballphilosophisch, sage ich jetzt mal, war es halt weg.
Du kannst ja angefressen sein. Will ich ja auch, dass die Menschen ihre Emotionen zeigen. Und sie sollen auch direkt sagen, was sich stört. Bin ich ein großer Freund von. Aber das ist halt einfach ein Unterschied, ob du da unprofessionell sitzt und einfach flapsig bist, so wie damals Klaus Augenthaler irgendwie, oder keine Ahnung. Es gab ja schon viele Beispiele von Trainern, die Steffen Baumgart und Co., die aber trotzdem ein Niveau gehalten haben, wo du dann Gesicht warst. Wo du auch dann nicht den einen… Also ich meine, du setzt dich hin und sagst, die Saison ist gelaufen. Das sind noch zehn Spiele zu gehen, als er das gesagt hat. Wie willst du denn, dass ein Faner kleiner eine Dauerkarte gekauft hat? Oder ich weiß nicht. Klar, die sind ja auch nicht doof, die Fans. Aber du willst ja trotzdem dann erwarten, dass die Mannschaft dann auch Folge hast. Gibt und wenn du dann die Ego-Show, die du gerade beschrieben hast, die sicherlich nicht nur der Kollege Reese dann am Tag legt, aber bei ihm fällt es halt auf, weil er eben der Fokusspieler ist, im Spotlight steht. Dann ist das, das geht nicht. Das finde ich einfach, das ist unprofessionell. Das hat nichts mit 1. und 2. Liga zu tun. Es ist menschlich ja, dass man enttäuscht ist, dass man vielleicht auch bockig und beleidigt ist oder denkt, die ganzen Mitspieler sind alle unfähig. Ich weiß es nicht. Aber das geht von der Kreisliga bis zur Bundesliga. Wenn du dann nicht der Teamplayer bist, dann hast du nicht der Kapitän zu sein und dann brauchst du auch keine Ansprüche anstellen, um mitzuspielen. Diese Spieler werden einfach nie ganz oben stehen. Das ist einfach so. Da kann er noch so talentiert sein. Bisher hat das nicht bewiesen, dass er eine Mannschaft zumindest dahin führen kann. Das ist so meine Sicht von außen, kann völlig falsch sein. Ich mag ihm persönlich auch gar nichts Böses. Ich kenne ihn ja gar nicht. Kann ganz lieber Junge sein, aber das ist das Bild, was die Hertha so nach außen hin gibt. Das ist nicht zum ersten Mal so in den letzten Jahren. Völlig überhöhte Ambitionen, Ansprüche. Schon bin ich sofort fertig, vom Investor her angefangen. Mich regt das immer auf, diese ganzen Nummern. Das sind so Ansprüche, wo ich mich immer frage, wo kommen die her? Du hast lange erste Liga gespielt, aber du musst, dass es keinen Lerneffekt gibt. Das finde ich immer total krass. In einer freien Wirtschaft würden diese ganzen Menschen einfach gar nicht in diese Position kommen. So, Entschuldigung.
Thomas, was ist dein Statement dazu?
Also ich bin grundsätzlich eigentlich immer ein Freund davon. Nicht nur grundsätzlich, ich bin ein großer Freund davon, wenn Vereine auch Ziele klar formulieren. Also ich kann mit diesem ganzen, auch bei uns hier, was ihr seit Jahren... Ja, wir wollen eine sorgenfreie Saison spielen. Also was soll das? Also sag doch einfach, du willst mehr Punkte holen als im letzten Jahr, dann ist doch das eine schöne Aussage. Das ist doch ein Ziel, an dem man sich messen kann. Und Hertha hat halt das ganz große Ziel ausgerufen. Finde ich persönlich jetzt erstmal gar nichts Verwerfliches daran, zu sagen, wir wollen aufsteigen. Ganz im Gegenteil, ich finde es cool, wenn Mannschaften oder Vereine eben auch ganz klar sich Ziele setzen und diese auch nach außen formulieren. Das ist mir lieber als dieses Phrasen-Gedresche von irgendwelchen Sportdirektoren, die dann sagen, wir wollen den nächsten Schritt machen und dieses ganze Quatsche. Da kann ja auch überhaupt nichts mit anfangen. Von daher finde ich das, was Hertha da gemacht hat, grundsätzlich erstmal schön. Natürlich machst du dich dann auch angreifbar, wenn es nicht funktioniert, das ist ganz klar. Du bist dann natürlich der Depp vom Dienst, wenn du dich dann hinschält, sagst, wir wollen aufsteigen und nach 24 Spieltagen dich hinschält, sagst du, das war es jetzt mit der Saison. Ich habe immer noch das Gefühl, ich weiß nicht, ich kann auch sehr naiv sein, aber vielleicht ist es auch tatsächlich von Leitel so, so eine letzte Patrone gewesen zu sagen, ich kitzel die Mannschaft jetzt richtig nach dem Spiel in Paderborn und sage hier so, da war es, Song ist vorbei, um vielleicht auch eine Reaktion zu erzeugen. Und da bin ich mal gespannt, wie die nächsten Wochen in Berlin laufen. Diese Liga zeigt ja eins auf beeindruckende Art und Weise. Du musst nicht schön Fußball spielen. Du musst erfolgreich Fußball spielen. Das zeigt Schalke auf sehr beeindruckende Art und Weise. Und wir spielen einen vermeintlich tollen Fußball. Guck, wo noch Tabelle stehen. Da kannst du dir nichts verkaufen. Du musst einfach spielen. Und wenn Hertha das jetzt vielleicht schafft und vielleicht war das genau, ich kann auch sehr naiv von mir sein jetzt. Einfach nur so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, weil ich eben auch der Meinung bin, Hertha ist halt auch, weiß ich nicht, also ich bin kein Fan von Hertha BST Berlin, aber ich muss sagen, ich hätte jetzt kein Problem, wenn wir in die 1. Bundesliga spielen würden. Und von daher kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass es vielleicht einfach so ein psychologischer Kniff nochmal war, da nochmal so wirklich seine letzte Patrone rauszahnt. Ich kitzel die jetzt wirklich bei der Ehre. Vielleicht klappt es, vielleicht doch nicht, vielleicht sehe ich das auch völlig falsch und Leitel weiß wirklich nicht mehr weiter. Es kann natürlich auch sein, dass Kevin auch vollkommen recht ist. Vielleicht ist er einfach mit seinen Dateien auch am Ende, weiß nicht mehr weiter und weiß vielleicht auch schon, dass am Saisonende vielleicht sogar schon viel entschluss ist. Wer weiß, was da intern besprochen ist. Aber ich sehe es immer noch so, vielleicht war das einfach nur, jetzt mache ich die Mannschaft vielleicht nochmal auf eine andere Art und Weise wach.
Ich glaube bei Leitel ist eben, dass er natürlich jetzt mit Hannover lange im Spotlight stand und jetzt eben mit der Hertha und man ihm mehrere Male quasi so das, inwieweit man ihm es vielleicht auch vor die Nase gesetzt hat. Dieses Zielaufstieg, bei Hannover war es ein bisschen anders als bei der Hertha jetzt, ist natürlich auch so eine Sache. Aber deshalb gucken wir da glaube ich alle auch nochmal durch so eine andere Brille durch, glaube ich. Weil wir eben irgendwie so das Gefühl haben, ja er wird ja irgendwie immer wieder als dieser Aufstiegstrainer oder als der Perspektiv-Trainer geholt. Aber es reichte halt bisher nicht. Und was er mit Führt geschafft hat, ich meine frag mich, wie gerne er den Stefan Neidl von ein paar Jahren wieder bei Führt sehen würde. Klar. Aber ich glaube, das ist das, warum da viele auch kritisch drauf sehen. Und ich empfehle an der Stelle natürlich einfach, bei Hertha Bays einfach mal vorbeizuschauen. Die werden euch das alles noch ein bisschen tiefer erklären können, als wir das hier machen können. Und ich weiß auch, wenn ich hier sitze und ich Mark, dann schaue ich natürlich meistens ein bisschen anders auf die Hertha, auch weil Mark und ich von Anfang an eben diesen Streitpunkt vor der Saison hatten, was Hertha BSC und die Ausstiegsträume betrifft. Das ist mir auch bewusst. Aber ich weiß eben auch, dass Mark natürlich auch so ein bisschen kritisiert hat, dass zum Beispiel Vergleiche mit dem HSV komplett hinken. Weil alleine die finanzielle Voraussetzung, die beide Vereine haben oder eben auch die Not, die bei Hertha hinter setzt– ich sage es gerne nochmal– natürlich ein Problem sind. Du hast dieses ewige Thema Olympiastadion versus eigene Stadion, was du natürlich nicht realisieren kannst, wenn du Jahr für Jahr 2. Liga spielst. Das willst du dir natürlich schon mit einer gewissen finanziellen Stabilität, mit Perspektive auf Bundesliga-Fußball bauen. Ich glaube, da hängt einfach so viel hinter, dass es natürlich auch eine emotionale Sache ist. Du formulierst ja auch, sagst, wir wollen aufsteigen, um mögliche Spieler zu holen, die du sonst vielleicht nicht kriegen könntest, um Sponsoren und sonstige Geldgeber hinter dich zu bekommen, die du sonst vielleicht nicht hinter dich bekommen würdest, wenn du jede Saison sagst, wir gucken mal, wo das hinführt. Ich verstehe das auch alles, Thomas. Da bin ich auf deiner Seite, also per se bin ich auch mehr Fan davon, zu sagen, wir wollen aussteigen, aber du musst das, was du forderst, auch füttern. Und wenn du alleine auf die– das haben wir immer wieder gesprochen– die Transferpolitik von Hertha BSC, die hängt da einfach hinterher. Du hast zur Winterpause noch Josep Brekalo geholt, so, ne, also wieder so jemand, wo du dir irgendwie vielleicht was Gleiches wie bei Jede Niko Medjajka erhofft hast. Du hast eben die teuren Verträge von Reze und Croissants. Gleichzeitig hast du mit Luca Schuller und Gröning zwei Stürmer, die wirklich also bei allem Respekt ihren Job absolut gar nicht erfüllen, ne, also und das kommt eben auch noch alles dazu. Und das sowas kann laufen, ne. Du hattest natürlich auch Pech mit Verletzungen mit Jugendspielern, die eigentlich gerade reinkamen und eigentlich wo du dachtest, boah, die bringen einfach noch mal Euphorie mit. Und das ist alles nicht auf, die verletzen sich dann etc. Das ist auch alles super bitter. Und ich verstehe da auch jeden Hertha-Fan mit Frust, ne. Also dafür habe ich zu viele in meinem Umfeld. Und ich bin auch per se der Meinung, der Bundesliga wird da ein zweiter Hauptstadtclub gut tun. Aber, also sagen wir auch mal so, würden die jetzt so noch aufsteigen, wissen wir, ob es in der Bundesliga funktioniert so? Also das ist natürlich auch immer die Frage, ne. Du musst als anders, das ist genau wie mit Schalke, wir erwarten von Vereinen wie Schalke und Hertha, dann natürlich auch ein ganz anderes Auftreten in der Bundesliga, als wir von Darmstadt, Elbersberg oder Paderborn erwarten würden. Das ist überhaupt nicht dispektierlich gegenüber den anderen drei Vereinen gemeint, aber weil eben Hertha und Schalke mit einem ganz anderen Anspruchdenken in die Bundesliga aufsteigen würden oder aussteigen und da sich selber auch eine andere Historie mitbringen, erwarten wir natürlich von ihnen auch was anderes und erwarten natürlich alle im Umfeld auch was anderes, ne. Also alleine auch aus Vereinspolitischer Sicht, so. Das waren noch meine drei Sens dazu. Jetzt habe ich euch in die Stille verabschiedet.
Nö, ich habe so viel geredet, ich wusste nicht, ob ich nochmal was sagen darf.
Ihr dürft immer was sagen, hier gibt es kein Redeverbot.
Nein, das ist alles richtig, aber trotzdem, finde ich, muss so ein Verein halt auch immer mal seine Grundpfeiler überdenken. Und natürlich ist da eine finanzielle Not hinter und auch Druck aus dem Umfeld. Und das ist mir alles bewusst. Ich sage ja auch nicht, dass man dann alles abreißt und von Null wieder anfangen muss. Aber und ich finde auch gut, wenn Mannschaften ihre Ansprüche formulieren. Also wir machen das ja so, wir wollen ja jedes Jahr uns verbessern. Damit sind wir jetzt ganz gut gefahren in der Saison. Ja, keine Ahnung. Aber ich finde, Hertha ist noch nicht reif. Da bin ich bei dir. Und damit kann es aus meiner Sicht auch schließen. Das hast du, glaube ich, ganz gut gesagt. Die sind nicht reif dafür, aufzusteigen. 40 Punkte zu diesem Zeitpunkt mit dem Spielverläufen. Puh, nee.
Also ich meine, das Einzige ist, wenn man mal zur Hinrunde guckt, kommen jetzt natürlich so einige Spiele, wo man in der Hinrunde eben noch Punkte geholt haben. Also man spielt jetzt eigentlich nur noch gegen Teams aus der unteren Tabellenhälfte, außer Kaiserslautern. Also du spielst jetzt eben zu Hause gegen Bochum, also ja, okay, auswärts in Düsseldorf, klammer ich, Düsseldorf würde ich jetzt auch in der aktuellen Lage mal so ein bisschen ausklammern. Dann eben auswärts bei Dresden, zu Hause gegen Kaiserslautern, auswärts Braunschrank, zu Hause gegen Kiel, auswärts Magdeburg, zu Hause gegen Fürth, auswärts bei Minervillefeld. So, das ist dein Endspurt. Also, da kannst du natürlich hinten raus noch gute Laune und Aufbruchstimmung verbreiten. Das ist natürlich auch schon so. Aber da wird eben ein großer Aderlass kommen im Sommer. Und ich meine, der Vorteil ist vielleicht dahingehend, dass du jetzt eben planen kannst und du kannst jetzt eben frühzeitig– und das ist vielleicht ein Vorteil gegenüber anderen Vereinen, die eben am Ende auch in der Liga bleiben werden, obwohl sie dachten, da geht vielleicht mehr– dass du da vielleicht einfach den Vorteil hast, dass du schneller reagieren kannst. Du kannst jetzt schon gewisse Gespräche führen. Das könnte ein Vorteil sein. Aber gleichzeitig ist halt auch klar, dass du das Ziel aufstieg, kannst du in der nächsten Saison so meiner Meinung nach erstmal nicht nochmal verkünden, weil das allein finanziell nicht möglich sein wird. Aus meiner Perspektive heraus vorsichtig formuliert. Und das eben auch so ein bisschen das, was ich jetzt quer gelesen habe von allen möglichen Leuten, die eindeutig näher am Verein sind, als ich es bin. Gut, dann würde ich aber sagen, schnell kurz bevor wir die 2-Stunden-Marke hier noch knacken. Ich dachte kurz, wir wären sehr gut in der Zeit. Na ja, sind wir natürlich immer noch. Und es hat mir sehr, sehr viel Spaß gemacht mit euch beiden. Vielen Dank erstmal an Thomas, der mal wieder dabei war. Vielen Dank, dass du uns hier wieder deine Perspektive auf den FCM, aber generell auch auf die restliche Liga gegeben hast. Und natürlich bei euch auch gerne im Podcast reinhören.
War sehr schön. Danke für die Einladung.
Und dann natürlich auch liebe Grüße an Kevin. Gehen raus an der Stelle. Danke, dass du auch wieder dabei warst. Und auch immer sehr, ihr beide seid immer sehr schnell dabei, euch auch zu melden. Und das schätzen wir euch natürlich auch sehr. Aber ich sage schon mal so, am Samstag, da ruht dann die positiven Gedanken kurz Richtung Paderborn.
Bitte? Warum? Ach so, da ist ja was. Die Karten waren so schnell wie bei kaum anderem Spiel vergriffen. Also das Auswärtskontingent.
Ja, ist ja auch ein kurzer Weg.
Ja, aber es war ja trotzdem nicht immer so.
Ja, stimmt. Wir haben bestimmt auch was mit der aktuellen Lage zu tun. Von beiden Vereinen wahrscheinlich. Aber wie gesagt, vielen Dank, dass du auch dabei warst.
Danke für die Einladung.
Dann würde ich jetzt sagen, schön, dass ihr wieder zugehört habt. Feedback gerne einfach im Forum hinterlassen oder bei YouTube lese ich es meistens auch. Und dann würde ich sagen, wir vielleicht nicht, aber dieser Podcast ist in zwei Wochen wieder zurück. Sollte nichts anderes passieren. Ich klopfe auf Holz. Macht's gut, bleibt gesund und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir freuen uns über ihre Unterstützung.
Lernst ein bisschen Geschichte und dann werden sie sehen, Herr Reporter, wie sich das damals im Parlament entwickelt hat.